[Applause]
greetings and welcome to the final
session of the Yale climate conference
I'm Jim Levinson director of the Jackson
Institute for global affairs the Yale
climate conference is the first of what
will be several conferences organized
under the auspices of the Kerry
initiative and the Jackson Institute is
proud to be the home of that Kerry
initiative the Jackson Institute is
focused on bringing to Yale some of the
most talented students from around the
globe once here we work to convene a
faculty that is comprised of world-class
scholars as well as leading
practitioners folks who have really
changed our world I sometimes describe
the goal of the Jackson Institute as
combining soft hearts with hard heads
bringing compassionate and caring people
dedicated to bettering our world and
then mixing in a healthy dose of the
tools needed for evidence-based
policymaking in this time of hard hard
hearts and soft heads the mission of
Jackson is a salient and as important as
ever the conference has embodied
Jackson's interdisciplinary approach to
addressing the world's pressing problems
sessions have been held at FAS at the
law school and at the school of
management as well as a fantastic
session earlier this morning here at
Wolsey a message that came from the
session this morning is that it's not
enough to know you've also got to do
that's the topic of this last session
and to introduce the speaker I'll hand
it off to the man to whom we are all
incredibly grateful upon completing his
term
the 68 United States Secretary of State
Secretary John Kerry could have done
about anything and Lord knows the man
deserved a break but instead of sitting
back
he's as busy as ever and I'm really
really glad that's the case please join
me in welcoming secretary Kerry
I do
thank you very much thank you thank you
thank you thank you thank you very much
I accept the nomination Oh
[Music]
the kiddie gym thank you very very much
thanks all for coming out we're gonna
have a really fun conversation I think
our next speaker as you know is smart
and talented he's kind he's committed
he's ethical he's good-looking and
despite all of that despite all of that
they like him in Hollywood who better my
you know I was thinking about this who
better to talk about the dangers of
climate change than a man who has
witnessed firsthand the damage caused
when an iceberg breaks off from a
glacier
I
this guy's played I you know a Connor I
mean a con-artist lawbreaker right-wing
reactionary billionaire and these aren't
just the people I served with in the
Senate folks these are these are the
characters this man has portrayed and I
also was thinking about in Titanic his
character froze to death in revenant he
almost froze to death so I don't know I
I thought if there was one guy who would
like global warming this was it over
here but in all seriousness I've enjoyed
a great friendship with Leo and we have
worked together and particularly over
the last few years I've had a chance to
see firsthand just how committed this
man is he's traveled the world he is a
UN messenger for peace he's come to our
conferences in the State Department we
started an oceans conference because a
lot of people aren't aware of the
relationship of what is happening to the
oceans and to life itself on this planet
and 51 percent of the oxygen that we
breathe comes from the oceans but the
oceans are increasingly in extremis of
the world's major fishing locations on
in all of the oceans almost every one of
them is either over fished or about to
be over fished and with the levels of
pollution from development and just
throw away
coupled with excess carbon dioxide that
is raising the acidification of the
ocean we see the bleaching of coral
reefs we see extraordinary downstream
negative impacts this is something that
leo has been deeply committed to trying
to prevent and working on and he came to
our oceans conference in the State
Department and his his foundation LDF of
the UH Nardo DiCaprio foundation
gave to the effort to have
accountability on the global fisheries
some seven million dollars in order to
kick off our efforts to have that
accountability to date to date the LDF
has committed to all kinds of efforts
and I'm gonna ask him about some of
those in a little while but whether it's
preservation of elephants or or work to
deal with the extinction of tigers or
preservation conservation he has now
given out some eighty million dollars
that he has personally raised and worked
on in order to have an impact so we're
deeply grateful for his commitment I'm
personally am grateful for his
willingness to take time to come to Yale
University today but not just Yale to
travel the world as this messenger of
peace and help to create the activism
that we need to deal with us we're going
to talk about that today you all may not
realize it and coming here today but you
are the agents of the change that we
need and we need a new level of
accountability in order to be able to
achieve what has to be done to keep the
earth's temperature from going over two
degrees centigrade we are way behind in
terms of what has to happen and we'll
talk about that today we intend to have
a two-way conversation Leos and sister
that he asked me some questions and
obviously I've insisted that I ask him
some questions so I think it's going to
be fun I want you all to join me in and
and and we're gonna start off before Leo
takes the podium we're gonna see about
three minutes or so of the clips from
before the flood which is the
documentary that he has worked to
distribute on a global basis so please
join me in welcoming our special guest
to discuss public activism and the way
in which we are going to save ourselves
from ourselves Leonardo DiCaprio
let's adjust I just sit right
yeah it's minute come on sit down down
just take the podium in I think we're
gonna start the clip somebody's gonna
run that well regardless oh we've known
about this for decades for over half a
century try to have a conversation with
anyone about climate change people just
- now climate change climate change and
change and the problem seems to be
getting worse and worse and worse the
truth is the more I've learned about
this issue and everything that
contributes to the problem the more I
realize how much I don't know paradise
that has been degraded and destroyed
we're knowingly doing this
I just want to know how far we've gone
and if there's anything we can do to
stop it
the US has been the biggest emitter of
greenhouse gases in history you're a
fossil addicted country we are doing
more investment in solar today than the
US is have the people in office still
don't believe in climate change why do
you think there is such opposition about
the science I think it's politics people
are so arrogant to think they can change
climate the environmental issues have
become the biggest reason for mass
demonstrations what we want to hold them
accountable
this is the most important issue of our
time question is can we change our
course in time you need 100 Giga factors
to transition through stainable energy
that would make the United States the
whole world all energy that's all that
I've seen on my journey shows us we had
the means of stopping this devastation
politicians do what the people want them
to do once the American people are
convinced the politicians will fall in
line very quickly
if we keep pushing there's no reason why
we can't solve this problem
the world is now watching we asked you
to protect it
are we and all living things we cherish
our history
[Music]
[Applause]
that was a three-year journey it brings
back a lot of memories
first off how's everyone doing this
afternoon thank you for having me here
and thank you to my good friend
secretary Kerry for not only his
commitment to these issues but his
amazing sense of humor this this
afternoon he had some pretty great jokes
and I didn't write any down so I have no
retorts but honestly our country does
owe you a great deal of debt for your
lifetime of public service I want to
thank you personally for your commitment
to our oceans and for fighting to stop
the March of climate change before it's
too late let's give them a huge round of
applause
you just saw my trailer for before the
flood we've watched as storms wildfires
droughts have have worsened since this
film has come out extinctions have also
become increasingly more frequent and as
some of us have also listened to
scientists as the scientific community
sounded the alarm bells about climate
change as far back as the 1990s the
Intergovernmental Panel on Climate
Change or the IPCC is made up of
scientists from every country on Earth
including the two biggest polluters the
United States and China this renowned
body presents their unanimous
peer-reviewed findings to world leaders
to the UN agencies and when they have
the trends have been nothing short of
grim in 1990 they told us that climate
change was real and being exacerbated by
human causes carbon emissions primarily
from fossil fuels in 1995 they warn that
concentrations of this pollution were
increasing in the atmosphere and would
be with us for decades even if we
stopped polluting immediately they also
warned that long-term economic impacts
of doing nothing about climate change
would be absolutely catastrophic in 2001
they reported the situation was getting
worse that humans are likely to be the
primary cause of climate change in 2007
their assessment included grim findings
that foreshadowed an increased frequency
and intensity of some extreme weather
events while climate change did not
cause these storms that we're seeing
right now it is without doubt in the
scientific community making the more
extreme and more destructive this news
hits so close to home
given what so many of our fellow
citizens here have experienced in the
United States throughout the Gulf
Florida and the Caribbean as they face
still more powerful storms coming right
this very second in 2014 their most
recent report the IPC's told that
atmospheric concentrations of carbon
dioxide methane and nitrous oxide at the
highest level are at the
levels in the last 800,000 years
alongside this astonishing fact was
their conviction that human influence on
the climate system is now absolutely
clear it is extremely likely with 95 to
a hundred percent probability that human
influence is the dominant cause of
climate change now these facts have been
presented the world time and time again
year after year for decades quite simply
we are knowingly doing this to ourselves
to our entire planet and we're risking
our very future and the cost of our
inaction these past couple weeks has
become even clearer Katrina a hundred
and eight billion sandy seventy-five
billion Harvey estimated atop a hundred
and eighty billion and Irma no one can
even project yet the mayor of Miami told
me personally what I was doing before
the flood that they spent four hundred
million dollars just to raise the roads
and install pumps to mitigate against
rising sea levels they're now imposing a
1 billion dollar tax to install similar
infrastructure and Boston estimates
they'll need over ten billion to do the
same to prevent catastrophic damage from
the next sandy or her that hits New
England and it's not just economic the
flooding this month in India and
Bangladesh has killed over 1200 people
and has displaced forty million yet with
all of this evidence this clear evidence
from the scientific community and the
mounting economic price tag there is
still an astounding level of willful
ignorance and inaction from the people
who should be doing the most to protect
us and every other living thing on this
planet last last December I met with
then-president electrum I was
accompanied by the head of my foundation
Terry Tama Ninh who ran the EPA for
California for seven years he presented
him with a comprehensive plan to
tackle climate change while also
simultaneously harnessing the economic
potential of green jobs we talked about
how the United States has the potential
to lead the world in clean energy
manufacturing and research and
development in fact with the commitment
from the Paris climate agreement it
could be the largest domestic
opportunity in all of American history
all we need is the political will to see
it happen and since that meeting the
world watched as this White House
appointed Scott Pruitt a climate denier
to the role of EPA Administrator and he
has since proposed a rollback on the
protection of public lands an end to the
EPA's oversight responsibilities for
water pollution and threaten the future
of the clean power plan a key to the
United States efforts to reduce carbon
pollution we watched at his at this as
this White House pulled us back from the
Paris climate agreement the landmark
blueprint thanks to Secretary of State
Kerry for containing global emissions
and slowing the increase in global
temperatures and we listened as they
said that these powerful hurricanes that
were seeing with Harvey and Erma did not
change the president's mind about
climate change I still believe that the
United States has the potential to lead
the world on this issue we can only hope
that the president begins to see it too
before it is too late for all of us now
the White House is not alone in
perpetuating the lie that there is there
was doubt about climate science Florida
Governor Rick Scott banned the words
climate change and global warming from
the state's business unfortunately no
governor is powerful enough to actually
ban climate change and today residents
of his state are rebuilding from
devastation that could have been
significantly less if the state
government was busy working for
solutions rather than banning words an
energy energy secretary Rick Perry as
governor of Texas also denied the
science of climate change and refused to
take action and today the state he once
led his struggle
to recover this utter lack of leadership
by officials who choose first to
preserve their short-term political
power rather than ensuring the livable
future on our planet means that we must
all do more now than any other time in
human history we have to take these
matters into our own hands we have to
stand up together and take on these
issues that unite us as Harvard
professor Gregory Mankiw told me before
the flood it was a clip in the and the
trailer you just saw when the public is
convinced the politicians will fall in
line very quickly what all politicians
and every nation on earth need to know
is this we have the technology to meet
100% of our energy needs from clean
renewable available cost-effective
sources that are at our fingertips right
now what is missing is is the fact that
some that countries and their and their
policies out there have set bold goals
and and we need more leadership from the
private sector at this point to reach
out and grab hold of this tremendous
opportunity to be the drivers of this
innovation to invest in these clean jobs
and understand the economic potential
for the future for the past day and a
half here at Yale CEOs and leaders from
some of the country's biggest companies
have said very much the same thing but
now we need more action from them so
please consider this as a call to action
a challenge to find new ways to power
your factories or stores their delivery
trucks to help your millions of
employees and customers to learn the
facts about climate change and what they
can do in their own lives to make a
difference and in any city state or
nation where you do business demand that
politicians accept climate science and
make bold commitments to change before
it is too late and that is where all of
us come in every single one of us has to
start to take action and that's why I
created
my foundation LDF in 1998 in addition to
funding the protection and restoration
of wild places endangered species oceans
and indigenous rights my foundation
supports the work of the solutions
project which is a trailblazing
nonprofit organization that have
actually drawn the blueprints for every
state in America and many other
countries around the world to go 100
percent clean by 2050 we're also proud
to support the UN's climate finance
initiative that is helping cities to
invest climate-friendly infrastructure
worth billions of dollars like making
buildings and lighting more efficient
replacing dirty fossil fuels massive
solar and wind farms and ending the
concept of waste by using everything
that was once buried in a landfill we've
recently launched the planet pledge fund
to use donations from forward-thinking
philanthropists to invest alongside
institutional investors in these kinds
of large-scale projects all over the
world and today knowing that actions
speak much louder than words on behalf
of LDF and my entire staff were very
proud to announce an additional 20
million dollars in new grants from my
foundation to over a hundred different
organizations at home and abroad that
are on the forefront of these urgent
existential challenges
but my message to you is this I urge
each and every one of you to join this
effort to get involved as much as you
possibly can your own future depends on
the participation of this issue here are
three simple things that everyone can do
first vote vote in next year's midterm
elections for politicians and candidates
who admit that climate change is real
who believe in the science and that it
is one of the most important issues we
need to address as a nation and make
sure that the next administration
believes in the science of climate
change and is committed to bold action
use your power as a consumer educate
yourself about this issue about this
issue educate yourself about the
companies that are providing the most
climate-friendly products and support
them boycott the companies that fund
climate done denial or contribute to the
problem with their products third
organize support highly effective
nonprofit organizations charitable
organizations that are working every
single day on the ground to implement
climate solutions and to defend the last
wild places on our planet that help
mitigate the damage from the onset of
climate change and for the students in
this audience today I urge you to become
that next great climate scientist that
next great economist that next great
public servant like our host John Kerry
here tonight and commit your career to
making a difference on this issue
there's a lot of helpful information on
my website but again my urgent message
to you is simply to get involved I wish
I could stand here and tell all of you
students that the impacts of climate
change including the most gut-wrenching
events we've seen this year alone won't
be a part of your future but that would
be a lie it's simply not the case after
three years of traveling the globe for
my documentary before the flood
I spoke to cow
people from all walks of life and saw
firsthand the real impacts of climate
change that are already occurring right
now and I could tell you this the harsh
reality is that your future your world
will be very different than it is today
there will be complexities and
challenges for the natural world and
humanity that will be unprecedented but
we can keep those devastating impacts
from getting even worse we can actually
minimize them if we all act now time is
up
the current events have become a global
wake-up call that must be heard all the
way from you to the private sector all
the way to Washington DC it is too late
for any of us to be too timid or too
ignorant or too silent we all have to
take action together now thank you very
much for your time
I was gonna mention a little about your
accomplishments in the environmental
field before I start with any of the
questions that I have for him
number one he helped organize the first
Earth Day in Massachusetts when he was
in his 20s that should be an inspiration
and participated and a local teachin
which is one of the first times he ever
spoke out in public is that is that the
case
elected to five terms in the United
States Senate where Al Gore called him
the Senate's best environmentalist
leading the filibuster that stopped
drilling in the Arctic National Wildlife
Wildlife Refuge and standing up to
special interests with John McCain to
write fuel efficiency standards for cars
and trucks as Senator he chaired the
Foreign Relations Committee and helped
to pass the New START treaty to reduce
the number of nuclear warheads between
the US and Russia the last arms control
treaty to pass the Senate the elevated
American leadership and made the
environmental stewardship a top made
environmental stewardship a top priority
beginning a dialogue with China and
helped pave the way for the United
States and China to work together to
unite the world behind the Paris climate
agreement on greenhouse gases and
finally he also brought oceans diplomacy
to the to the State Department founding
the our ocean conference among nations
to galvanize action an effort that lives
on today and an area where secretary
Kerry continues to lead heading to Malta
next month to press forward on
leadership as a global oceans ambassador
so thank you for all your not only all
your political contributions that
everything that
environment I guess I want to first
start off by asking you as a young man
and being such a steward of our planet
how did you first become involved on a
your realization of the fragility of our
planet but when did you first start to
learn about the science of climate
change so let me let me just a
disclaimer folks we did not have
prearranged that little advertisement I
apologize
let me can I can I want to react if I
can just come back to that but I really
want to say something based on what you
said to everybody because I was looking
out there at all of these students and I
couldn't help but think back in time as
you were giving them a charge and saying
look you guys have got to be involved
and you got to get out there and so
forth and I know that it's really easy
to kind of sit there and you sort of
process it for a couple of minutes and
say yeah I've got to get out there but
then you get out of this building and
you're going to go back to class or
homework or the next day or whatever is
going on in your personal life and it's
always hard to kind of really focus and
carried on but I just I want to say to
you I mean I emphasize this you as
nicely as humbly as I can and not as a
lecture but just as a statement of fact
that what you're learning here is not
just to get a job and go be part of the
structure and
you know so to live your life and be
successful and happy what you're
supposed to be learning here in addition
to that is citizenship and everything
that Leo just talked about the urgency
of what is happening on climate cannot
be overstated but you have to be careful
not to state it in a way that it
terrifies people so much they just don't
want to get out of bed in the morning
and they say you know I can't deal with
this and there's some where the sweet
spot of sufficient motivation measured
with all the possibilities of what can
happen
but I will tell you after all these
years of experience in public life if
you don't do this if you don't decide
that you're going to be the agent of
change and accountability it isn't going
to happen
it really isn't going to happen and I
can remember there's sort of four events
that stood out during my time at Yale
freshman year we almost had a nuclear
war over Cuba and we had the Cuban
Missile Crisis sophomore year I was on a
soccer field in the middle of a game
against Harvard to this day I haven't
looked up or remember I can't remember
who won it because the ripple went
through the stands and we learned that
President Kennedy had been assassinated
and so we lived through that and the
next year we were busy sending people on
buses from high street down to the south
in our own country to end segregation
and I remember driving down there in a
spring vacation with my close friend
here at Yale and we I was shocked by
signs that said you know no colored
white only in our country you don't see
that now and it's because a lot of young
people decided they were going to change
all of that and then the senior year of
Vietnam
you know people's lives were changed
because we had a draft and a whole bunch
of young people in America couldn't get
out of the draft or didn't have the
choices some people had at Yale so we
had Vietnam 58,000 people died in a war
that never should have been fourth but
it was young people that ended the war
was young people who created the women's
movement and began to break the glass
ceiling it was young people who broke
the back of Jim Crow in the United
States and helped to pass the Civil
Rights Act of 1965 and I say all of this
to you because this challenge of global
climate change is as big as it gets and
how much evidence do you need in a few
years we're going to have open passage
in the Arctic there'll be no ice in the
summer
I think Leo you've been up to Greenland
we've been above the Arctic Circle stood
on the ice sheet over the Arctic which
is on rock so every bit of ice that is
there that is melting is an add on to
the volume of the oceans and I look down
a whole 100 feet deep and I saw a river
running a torrential river as the ice is
melting off I went over the fjord you
saw it what's called calving as the ice
falls off of the fjord which you saw the
photos of in the movie a moment ago
every day 86 million metric tons of ice
are falling off of that fjord and
floating out into the ocean to melt and
that is enough water each day to fulfill
all the needs of Greater New York for
one entire year each day but it's not
it's melting sea level rise greater
droughts greater fires we just broke
three records in the last couple of
weeks
irma the most high-velocity cyclonic
effect in
and in a hurricane winds over 185 miles
an hour for 24 hours
harvey greatest amount of rainfall in
history in one storm and then the fires
that are decimating the western part of
our country in record amounts and so
forth so I'm not going to go through the
whole long list but the point I'm making
is that the evidence is overwhelming
absolutely overwhelming what is
happening to us now and in Paris we made
an agreement a hundred and ninety six
nations came together and said our goal
is to keep the warming of the Earth's
temperature at two degrees centigrade
and if we can one degree and a half
saturated well you know we're already
reaching a tipping point beyond which
you can't come back last election day I
went to Antarctica many people said you
know what's scary know something about
the outcome of the election is he
planning to stay there and believe me
when I got there and found out I almost
thought about staying there but but the
I listened to a scientist in New Zealand
scientist and thereabout
I think it's 17 or 23 I've forgotten the
exact number of different countries have
scientists down there doing the research
and I went out over the West Antarctic
Ice Sheet three and a half miles three
miles deep in places and they showed me
the fragility of that ice sheet now
which has warmer water coming underneath
it and creating instability and they
predicted the possibility that a very
large chunk of it may break off well
just a few weeks ago in the New York
Times front page story about a huge rift
in the act Arctic ice sheet and the
Larsen ice sheet is already broken off
with a size of the state of Rhode Island
that's flow
into the ocean folks it's happening and
I'm just gonna be blunt with everybody
here because there's no time here to
sugarcoat this stuff the people who want
to be doing something about it at a
national level in our nation are not
they're even making a mockery out of the
idea we had a United States Senator
who's the chairman of the Environment
Committee bring a snowball on to the
floor of the United States Senate at a
certain time of winter and say look
here's snow it's happening there can't
be global warming please this this is
urgent now just quickly summarize it by
saying you this is am I just going to
throw this at you and leave you to your
own devices let me tell you what
happened back in 1970 when I was part of
what Leo described to you the first
Earth Day April 22nd 1970 before I
protested against the war I was freshly
back from Vietnam but I hadn't yet
processed the war in a way that led me
to go organize veterans and demonstrate
the way I wound up doing but I but I
knew I was going to go out there and
make a difference on the environment
because my mother to go to it's question
had been an ardent environmentalist and
it was just part of the ethic of
Massachusetts of New England of my
upbringing of my education here at Yale
and elsewhere that you exercise
responsibility you conserve you preserve
you think about the future so that's
what led me to Earth Day but 20 million
Americans came out of their homes on the
same day 1970 at that time that was
unprecedented and everybody's whoa
something's happening here but the real
magic of it was not twenty million
people coming out on the one day it was
those 20 million people deciding they
were going to translate their presence
into political action and what they did
was target what we did was target the 12
worst votes in the United
States Congress we labeled them the
Dirty Dozen for their horrible votes on
their environment and we targeted their
districts congressionally and in the
next election seven of the twelve lost
their seats and I'm telling you as a
former elected official there is nothing
like the loss of one of your colleagues
to stiffen your spine and collect your
brain and that's what happened all of a
sudden environment became a voting issue
think about that voting issue and that
accountability produced the Clean Air
Act which you benefit from today the
Safe Drinking Water Act which you
benefit from today Marine Mammal
Protection Act Coastal Zone Management
Act safe drinking water and we created
the EPA the United States of America
didn't even have an Environmental
Protection Agency until 1972 and Richard
Nixon who was not known for his
environmental agenda was forced to sign
it into law because environment had
become a voting issue now my my
strongest message to you here today is
we need that change now we need young
people I mean how many people voted in
the last election in America 55 percent
or so I've been the countries I just
came back from Kenya where I was leading
the delegation to monitor the elections
seventy something percent and it was
down from what it had been four years
ago seventy something percent compared
to us I went to the Philippines in 1986
to lead the effort there to get rid of
the dictator Marcos and I watched people
stand in the hot Sun for 12 hours have
their thumb printed with ink to prove
that they had voted and it was 85 90
percent of people voted so you cannot go
to a great university like Yale and not
accept with that privilege
the responsibility of creating a voting
issue over something that is literally a
force of mass destruction growing in its
capacity to threaten life on this planet
and my prayer is that every single one
of you are going to be inspired by Leo's
film and inspired by the facts and
recognize the responsibilities of
citizenship to do this to pull us back
from the brink and you know the good
thing I'm telling you we're lucky on
this this is not something where we
don't know what the solution is we know
what it is we have it it's already been
discovered it's energy policy solution
to climate change is not to spit Coal
Fired coal dust up into the air it's to
move to the new technologies and find
others that we know will provide for a
base and nowadays solar and wind bottom
line I'm telling you are absolutely
competitive with coal we shouldn't build
one more coal-fired power plant anywhere
in the world if we're gonna beat this
challenge it's that simple
well set
how did you get involved it what
prompted you sudden later to tell you
the truth I lived in Los Angeles I
didn't grow up in amongst nature
whatsoever but it was really
documentaries it was IMAX films about
the rainforest that made me I was
actually looking at one of my first
interviews when I was 13 years old and I
just started doing television and
commercials and I said I want to be an
environmentalist I was committed to this
issue was a passion of mine and it
wasn't until a little later in life that
I actually wanted to become an activist
that I felt like I could use my voice
that I could make a difference I could
start a foundation but what's been
amazing to watch over the last 22 years
of speaking out 21 years of speaking out
about this issue ever since it was
really a road to learning more and that
actually brought me to meet Al Gore in
the White House when he was then vice
president and he as I discussed the
documentary he drew a map of planet
Earth he drew our atmosphere around it
and he started talking about this thing
that was called global warming and I had
no idea what he was talking about I'd
never heard of this issue didn't even
know it was a threat and then it became
this somewhat of an obsession of mine to
learn more to learn more but to become
more active because to me it represented
the most existential crisis humanity has
ever faced we have dealt with famine we
have dealt with war historically
throughout time but when he started
talking about chemically changing our
planet in an irreversible fashion that
will threaten all life on Earth that was
like the most surreal scientific science
fiction movie I could ever imagine
and I started speaking out on this issue
and what has been amazing for me as
somebody who isn't a college graduate
who isn't a scientist who's just a
citizen that wanted to get involved in
this issue
but being on this sort of campaign so to
speak for for global warming climate
change you realize the amazing inaction
at this country has taken you go to
anywhere else in the world there is no
argument about climate change there is
no argument people accept it as a fact
this is the only country in the world
where we have a political party that
argues what is now basically scientific
fact I mean it's like arguing whether
gravity exists or not I mean you guys do
exams if you get 95% to 100% or you get
an a a plus I mean that is the
scientific consensus there is there's no
argument this and yet in the media two
people are able to have an argument one
person denies it the other person is for
it it creates this everlasting argument
which is what so many of these
organizations that are funded by fossil
fuels want to happen they want to
continue the argument of what is now
peer-reviewed scientific fact and it is
an absolute absurdity and the as the
rest of the country and I want to talk
about the Paris agreement as the rest of
the countries of the world are moving
forward with this landmark agreement
that you set in place here we are the
United States we were the the largest
polluting country in the world China
surpassed us a year to ago but per
capita with with some three hundred you
know three hundred million plus people
China has over a billion per capita were
absolutely the most polluting country in
the world yet we have pulled out of what
was now the the best shot we had to
tackle this crisis so how do you feel
about the future of the Paris agreement
now that the United States is pulled out
of it a is my question and B what do you
think we all need to do as a country to
make this
issue more prevalent in in in the
zeitgeist what what do we have to do is
citizens as people to try to push this
agreement for it and also what do you
say to critics that talk about to do to
get to that 2 degree threshold which is
that turning point that the restrictions
and the Paris agreement were not enough
well I think just the Paris agreement
had been preceded by some of you may
have read about the Kyoto agreement
previously and in the Kyoto agreement
which so laid the predicate for how he
had to deal with Paris there was a
mandatory level of reduction for four
major enemies in the world why because
some 20 countries are fundamentally
responsible for the most of the
emissions of the world and the island
states for instance or Bangladesh or
other people feel the negative impacts
but they're not responsible they're not
contributing amounts to make the
difference in climate change so when we
wouldn't pass Kyoto because there was
sort of a pushback within the United
States Senate and the Congress that wait
a minute China's not part of this
India's not part of this because they're
developing countries and they to reduce
and that's a legitimate complaint they
weren't able to be mandatory reductions
so when we approached Paris we said all
right we need a different equation we've
got to get every country in the world
engaged in this but we're clearly not
going to succeed in passing something
through the United States Senate or the
House if it requires more from the
United States then the market will bear
politically and otherwise so and we also
had a problem in Copenhagen four years
before the Paris agreement China had led
the g77 countries the developing
countries to object anything happening
in Copenhagen so we knew that if we were
going to get it something done we had to
change the equation with China so within
six weeks of my being Secretary of State
I went to China and negotiated with the
Chinese and we got the Chinese to agree
that we would have a working group that
would try to see if we could come to an
agreement on an approach where each of
our countries did what our countries
were able to do and then stand up
together and lead the rest of the world
to the watering hole in Paris so it
worked one year later President Obama
and President Xi were able to stand up
together in Beijing and announce what
each country would do in an effort to be
serious about Paris that was a sea
change moment that was the moment when
Paris became possible and then we went
to Paris and a hundred and six Nations
agreed each of them to a plan so when
President Trump says to the people of
the United States I'm pulling out of
Paris because Paris places an undue
burden on the United States of America
my friends the president United States
is not telling America the truth that's
just not true it doesn't place any
burden on the United States it only
places what we agreed as Americans we're
capable of doing at our schedule our
desire within our limits of technology
and so the president has now taken this
country of ours which led the effort to
create Paris which is the leading one of
the leading emitters it's number two in
the world in terms of climate and pulled
it out of the Paris agreement claiming
falsely that it is an excessive burden
for our nation all the President had to
do
we'll say you know what I think the
Obama folks asked too much of us I'm
gonna do less I'm gonna change the
targets but it could have stayed in
Paris the result of pulling out is that
we have ceded to China alone leadership
which the United States had we're going
to make it much more difficult for our
businesses to be able to do business in
this sector our credibility is hugely
damaged and we lose momentum which is
absolutely vital to our ability to be
able to meet the goals now here's the
upside and there is an upside to all of
this as quite a remarkable story about
citizens and about leadership
notwithstanding what President Trump has
announced that he is pulling out I'm
proud to tell you today the American
people are not pulling out and today
right here on this stage we had Governor
Brown of California governor Inslee of
the state of Washington talking about
what their states are going to continue
to do to live up to Paris and so you
know I can sit here and tell you that we
have 29 states in America that have
passed what is called a renewable
portfolio standard so those 29 states
have laws requiring them to now
diversify and get into alternative
renewable sustainable energy that's
seventy percent of the American
population and represented in those 29
states because it includes big states
like California New York and so forth in
addition to that we have eight states in
America that already have a voluntary
renewable portfolio standard so doing
your best Yale math that's 38 states of
the United States of our 50 all of which
are committed to move forward to
alternative renewable energy equaling
80% of the population of the United
States of America so guess what the
president has hurt us with a
false rationale for doing something that
we didn't have to do he has pulled
America out of leadership position he's
hurt us by not being at the table to
help shape this going forward but
America because of the commitment of
people in those states we are going to
meet our Paris goal and I believe
personally we will exceed the Paris goal
as a result of the commitments that have
already been made now here's the problem
Paris doesn't do it when we went to
Paris we knew that we were not setting a
goal that was going to achieve the 2%
because we couldn't because we couldn't
do mandatory so what's the benefit
what's the great virtue of it here's the
virtue of it when the world's business
community saw 196 countries all
committing to move in this new direction
what we wanted to do was send a message
to the marketplace and here's what's
happened since Paris for the first time
in history by a factor of two twice as
much money has been invested as a result
of 196 countries making a decision twice
as much money as invested in renewable
alternative sustainable energy as in
fossil fuels for the first time in
history and now in America solar energy
is growing 17 times faster than the
regular economy the fastest single
growing job in America is wind energy
technician so I'm able to say I think
Leo the importance of this is I believe
after all my years in the public sector
I don't think government is going to
make the decision that's going to save
us I think Elon Musk or Sergey Brin or
you know Larry Page whatever Google
that the Silicon Valley the next
technology wave it's going to be the
private sector investing in the biggest
marketplace the world has ever seen
which is the energy market of the future
and that energy market is going to go
from four to five billion people today
to nine billion people by 2050 and you
guys are going to see and live an energy
revolution on the face of this planet
the real question is not whether we'll
do it
it's whether we're going to do it fast
enough whether we can meet the goal and
and so you know what Trump has done is
slow down momentum give up leadership
tell something patently untrue to the
American people and and that in the you
know that's that's not the way I viewed
the presidency of the United States not
you know it's part of this challenge we
have today you mentioned it a moment ago
right I mean Jerry Brown today sat here
and said you know we've reached a point
where one side will say 2+2 is 4 and the
other side will say 2+2 is 5 and people
in the news media give both of them
equal presentation and they don't
deserve it so we have to have a change
and a shift in so how we're dealing with
this what do you think is gonna happen
from an economic standpoint because as I
mentioned earlier Terry who ran was the
head of my foundation ran the EP for
California for seven seven years created
a lot of California's innovative
environmental policies handed him a
report this is now President Trump this
thing and tried to explain quite simply
as you said this could be America's
largest economic opportunity in history
you talked about on your campaign
wanting to rebuild the Rust Belt create
American jobs never before has there
been 196 countries that need to fulfill
those commitments with the Paris
agreement you now have all these
countries around the world saying we
want solar we want when we need new
technologies help supply that to our
countries and by taking ourselves out of
the equation
we have lost that opportunity so which
brings me to my other question who's
gonna fulfill that that void China has
now committed to saying that they're
gonna reduce all cars with internal
combustion engines by a certain date and
they're gonna have all electric all
electric fleets of cars the other major
polluter which is India which is heavy
reliant heavily reliant on coal they're
trying to make waves in this who's gonna
fulfill all these obligations now and
will America suffer not only from the
Hurricanes that we've experienced and
and the onset of climate change will
America suffer economically long term by
not engaging in that process I think
absolutely yeah we will suffer will
suffer because there'll be a backlash
against American business for not
participating in the process in a way
unless the technology is so superior I
mean in the end businesses do what works
for the bottom line and so if we have
some breakthrough technology we won't be
handicapped but if it's our technology
against two or three other countries on
a even basis and it's fairly
indistinguishable between them we're
gonna get hurt
we've lost credibility here we've lost
leverage you know at one moment we're
leading the world to Paris and the next
moment we're pulling out of Paris and
and people all over the world are
scratching their heads and saying so
what's going on here and the problem
it's not just Paris its TPP its
leadership the questions about NATO I
mean it builds up
in the end but look you you you you've
traveled now I don't know how many many
miles but you've been all around the
world several times in the last three
years making this movie what did what
did you drive what did people say to you
about America during that period of time
because we're a big polluter they're
completely confused about our actions to
tell you the truth that lady in India
that that is in the trailer really
started to attack me on a personal level
and I had to explain to that I'm not
completely responsible for all of the
United States global emissions but she
attacked my lifestyle the average
Americans lifestyle in comparison to
somebody from her country but you know
it's puzzling because yes I've seen I
went to I've seen Arctic sea ice
disappear to the point where you know
we're gonna have new shipping routes
because all the sea ice is gonna melt
which not only creates you know
environments for and breeding grounds
for so many so much marine life but is a
mitigator of climate ultimately you know
that's why we're seeing the the severity
of these hurricanes right now because
our oceans are warmer and we don't have
enough you know cool air from the north
to to to combat it I've seen you know I
went all over Indonesia and the lesser
ecosystem I've never seen a
manifestation of human greed the way I
saw that I saw in these forests where
you know the third largest force in the
world was almost completely wiped out
for the palm oil industry I went to the
top of Greenland where scientists
explained to me that you know soot from
you know coal-fired power plants in
China and around the world are creating
a black film over all of Greenland which
is making it like Swiss cheese it may
seem like Greenland still there but
underneath that is these are these
massive canals and black belts melting
out into the ocean
the
on set and the reality of climate change
if you travel around the world is
absolutely apparent you talk about in my
documentary the refugee crisis people
don't attribute the fact that we have
these massive amount of refugees that
are leaving their homes because of
desertification they need to go to urban
environments and and and and continue
their lives because they've lost
everything that they have we're seeing
wildfires all over California like we've
never seen before the evidence is all
around the world
what is puzzling to me is still how we
this incredibly progressive country I
know there's a great documentary called
merchants of doubt' which I encourage
everybody to see because in it they talk
about how the fossil fuel companies have
used the same disinformation campaign
and strategy that the tobacco companies
used in the 50s and 60s to get people to
continue smoking they use this same
people almost PR spinners to be able to
perpetuate disinformation about the
science of climate change so you have
all these phony front groups these
organizations that like the Heartland
Institute these organizations that say
well climate change isn't real the
science hasn't figured out there isn't a
consensus I still want to argue this and
we're it's like a that's like hamsters
in a wheel we keep talking about what is
now scientific fact why have our oil
coal and gas companies people like the
Koch brothers who funded so much of this
information and that's you can read
about that I'm not saying anything
controversial why have they've had such
a stranglehold on our political system
whereas other countries talk about
climate change like I said as if it were
gravity you know why why is this country
still
so influenced by these forces at be its
and look that's the question folks and
we had secretary Jim Baker over in the
law school a little while ago he's been
a Secretary of State a secretary of the
Treasury he's been a White House chief
of staff he was chairman of for prat
campaigns for president United States a
very capable distinguished public
servant and he has put forward a plan to
price carbon he and former Secretary of
State and Treasury George Shultz and
others secretary Hank Paulson the reason
this is important they're all
Republicans and they're all pretty
conservative but they are trying to
change the debate and today at the
session we just had at the Law School
for the first time in a several years we
had Senator Lindsey Graham of South
Carolina and we had Senator John McCain
of Arizona both wanted to come they
couldn't come at the last minute because
of legislation in the Senate but they
videoed in and both of them made
powerful statements about how critical
it is they accept that global climate
change is happening they accept that
human beings are causing it and they
accept that we're going to have to
change what we're doing that's a huge
leap compared to this denial that is
pervasive within one particular party
but the key is we're not going to win
this battle if all we do is point the
finger at the other party we have to
find a compromise of some kind in which
neither side wins or loses in essence
and there may be a way to do that
through carbon pricing where you kind of
buy an insurance policy when you have I
mean let's say you're a denier you you
don't believe the science completely
well okay it's hard to do that when 97
percent of the scientists of the world
who deal with climate all agree and most
of the leaders of the world
come to an agreement but let's say we'll
give you the benefit of the doubt then
how what should you do well logic would
say public people people in positions of
responsibility need to embrace the
precautionary principle you buy
insurance not because you know your
house is going to burn down but because
you wanted to prevent it if it did burn
down you want to replace it you buy
insurance in your automobile etc etc etc
well we should be buying insurance for
those who don't accept the facts and
that insurance policy would be the
pricing of carbon where you can return
money to the system in a way that builds
the infrastructure necessary to prevent
the worst from happening and and what I
keep saying to people is what's the
worst thing that could happen if you buy
into the if you do accept that climate
change is happening and so you put in
place clean energy technology what's the
worst that happened you create millions
of jobs you have cleaner air you live up
to your environmental responsibilities
to the next generation you get energy
independence we have it now because of
fracking but you we didn't for a long
time but we maintained energy
independence because you got your own
energy it's clean you're developing it
and and you create you have a whole new
economy that's based on clean that's
literally the worst that would happen to
you if you buy into this become a world
leader in terms of the environment as
well as the jobs what's the worst that
happens if they are wrong if you're
talking in terms of just buying
insurance obviously the worst that
happens if they're wrong is the end of
life on the planet as we know it
sheer catastrophe so which one of those
two choices it's it's a no-brainer you
buy the insurance and and so that's what
we have to sell the people now don't
require them to lose
their ideology or heart positioning but
get them to see that there's a logic to
buying insurance against the odds that
the other side may be right I don't you
feel that works or not I mean you've
made this argument to people Leo what I
mean you must occasion have been
exasperated by the contrary in response
you get do you find there's something
else that breaks through do you have a
sense that III feel inept and having a
dialogue or conversation with people
that don't believe but change to tell
you the truth I think that Who am I to
argue if I were a politician and I was
up on the podium you look at the last
debates that we've had how much time was
devoted to what could be what is the
most important issue facing all of
humanity so little time was spent on
this issue and if I was a candidate that
was arguing to make progress on this
issue I'd say how could you be so car
you a scientists are you a climate
scientist how could you argue that this
isn't real when people have devoted
their lives thousands of you in the
documentary they don't even talk about
97% they talk about 99% of the
scientific community having an absolute
consensus that man is contributing to
this issue so I feel inept I feel I feel
I don't engage
I don't engage because I don't feel like
I have the authority to to have anything
other than the opinion of the scientific
community but I assume after your
travels and after the work you've done
with the film and the many questions
you've heard about it
that your sense is that the difference
is going to be made through political
accountability that that if we don't
hold politicians accountable who are not
moving for
we're doing this yeah they should be
thrown out of office look I was recently
up on a particular stage for a
particular film recently and that's all
I talked about I didn't want to talk
about anything else I said not this
might be my one opportunity here in my
lifetime I remember that I did this film
called the revenant between us Leo and I
have won Oscar and it was a internal
question whether to bring up something
as sensitive and polarizing as this but
we experienced that firsthand while
making the film I got a lot of flack
from the Canadian government saying that
these were Chinooks and heat waves but
we had to stop filming for months at a
time we had to relocate to the southern
tip of Argentina just to be able to find
snow because the weather patterns were
completely unpredictable and completely
off it was a reality to me and the film
was about the natural world so I wanted
to speak out about that but yes it's up
to all of us this generation like you
were talking about your generation being
able to march to organize to to activate
their their their their their friends
their families people in their
neighborhoods to get out and vote that
is absolutely one of the most important
things we can do in this country we
should not have people in office that do
not believe in in facts and rhetoric and
truths in modern science that are able
to manipulate and risk the entire future
of of this entire generation you all
need to become active you need to be
involved in this issue you need to do
what you can because truly from making
this film I've seen how much is at risk
and the list goes on and on from the
wildfires to the Hurricanes to rising
sea levels to
you know climate refugees as you spoke
about the documentary I mean we're
seeing the the impacts of climate change
every single day and they are just
getting worse and worse and worse each
year is getting hotter than the next
even if you don't believe in science
whatsoever it's hard not to see the
tactile you know the the the tangible
things that we see on this planet that
seem so incredibly obvious so you know
the more I've learned about this issue
the more I've become terrified to tell
you the truth I'm doing a new
documentary about methane you've done so
much work on oceans the protection of
our oceans the health of our oceans the
fact that so much of this carbon is
being absorbed in the oceans we're
actually not even seeing on land the
ramifications of the amount of carbon
that we're doing into the atmosphere
because the oceans are absorbing so much
of it and they're at capacity now so I'm
really scared
I am really scared for the future
because the scientific community is
saying that though the oceans can can no
longer absorb that much carbon they're
become they're becoming the theirs
they're becoming acidified they're
they're warmer we're seeing dead zones
all around our oceans and the methane
issue is something that absolutely
terrifies me like I said I'm doing a new
documentary we talked about this inert
methane that is underneath the ocean
floor all over the world it's frozen
it's it's not harmful to us in any way
but is 40 to 50 times more of a powerful
greenhouse gas than carbon and we're
seeing methane leaks all over the world
starting to sprout up because of the
temperature of our oceans these leaks
are starting to happen we're not going
to be and warming leads to more warming
so that carbon is now making the methane
start to leak out and that's 40 to 50
times more of a powerful greenhouse gas
than carbon we're at that turning point
right now and we're going to look back
at this moment in history and frankly
this admit
stray ssin and certain people are going
to be vilified for not taking action
they really are and it's up to this
generation it's up to all of you to
really get involved and make a
difference because as I said in the
documentary what I saw on my travels
absolutely terrified me it was
terrifying well this is a sobering way
to sort of bring this to a close but I
want to confirm a couple things folks
while the facts are terrifying if you
look at them and presume you do nothing
that's terrifying thus far we have not
been doing enough but as I said earlier
the solution is there it's right there
we know what we can do we put smart
grids in places we don't even have a
grid in the United States of America do
you know that there's a great big hole
in the middle of the country no grid we
can't take wind energy from the southern
part of our country and sell it in the
north we can't take wind energy from
Minnesota or Iowa and sell it in the
south we have a West Coast grid East
Coast grid a little bit of a grid across
the north of the country and then Texas
has its own grid that's it so the
solution is what it's to build a grid
it's to use the ingenuity and investment
that we have in America it's not hard
what's hard is the politics and you who
can help change the politics I have this
little thing I'm holding in my hand here
I was given this when I went down to
Antarctica it's air from the South Pole
and on this vial it says cleanest air on
earth let me get ahead of that right
[Applause]
actually when I finished when I finished
saying what I want he'll regurgitate it
won't want it because the cleanest air
on earth is well above what scientists
tell us is permissible and that's at
Antarctica four hundred and one point
six parts per million that is so about I
mean 350 parts per million is what
scientists tell us we need to hold it to
in order not to have a tipping point so
look bottom line I think Leo made a very
eloquent statement to you about what you
have to do I'm not going to say more
about the activist and I want to leave
you one thought if there are are moments
when you look at these issues and as I
said in the very beginning you may be
overwhelmed by it or intimidated and say
hey I don't know I'm just one person
Bobby Kennedy back in 1968 when we were
fighting our part ID in South Africa
went to South Africa and gave a speech
to people there and he said that the
greatest of all dangers is futility the
belief that there's nothing that a man
or a woman can do against the enormous
array of the world's ills but each of us
he said can work to change a small
portion of events and in the total of
all those acts will be written the
history of this generation each time a
man or woman strikes out against
injustice or works to improve the lot of
others he or she sends forth a tiny
ripple of hope that crossing each other
from the million different centers of
energy and daring they can sweep down
the mightiest walls of oppression or
resistance that's the trick that's what
happened in our party that's what
happened in civil rights that's what
happened in some in the environment so
many other things it can happen again
and if you listen to Leo and what he
just said to you in terms of the urgency
and and what should motivate you I'm
confident you're going to
go out and do it so thank you first of
all leo thank you for taking time to
come here what happened thank you all
thank you very very much thank you
they're gonna get that photo okay
you
you